salut aujourd'hui on est vendredi de
vendredi je donne des cours de guitare
maintenant pas du tout et heureusement
pour vous mais aujourd'hui je suis avec
olivier et de choses ça lui a lié sa vue
fabien est à guitares et à cause de toi
le monde va encore dire que je suis
petit combien tu mesure 1 m 65 ans 1 m
90 600 chaînes de la vivre et lui donne
des cours de guitare qui explique
comment il est demeuré cours de guitare
des démos de guitare au super merci
d'être venu chez moi
certains de nos plaines moi je vais
prendre ta guitare et je vais te
mentaliser enfin je vais en saluant la
guitare elle pense à la mineure on va
faire un truc a pas d'accord et à base
de gestes de mémoire corporelle hockey
puisque tu vois si si je te dis sol
majeur par exemple je veux être ton
cerveau sait exactement comment
contracté muscle a comme pour faire un
solde ces mamans bar exactement on va
essayer de jouer avec sa grande première
j'ai réfléchi à ça ce matin je suis au
lit vié qui vient la maison donc toi tu
peux penser à des accords dans ta tête
accord majeur avec ordinaire a en
l'occurrence moi ce que je veux pour le
premier coup ces désaccords majeurs
d'accord d'accord là c'est le genre ok
pour le premier coup on va on va essayer
ça c'est drôle parce que c'est vraiment
j'ai jamais si je suppose qu'il va dire
je vais devenir un manche de guitare au
québec et olivier alors j'aime être ici
when they droitier ou gaucher ou
droitier
donc tu tiens ta guitare est comme ça
elle fume étude le rythme ici donc ça
s'arrête à manger des guy paquet
d'accords je te demande et d'enchaîner
les accords a en fait eu les enchaîne et
tu peut gratter dans vie de la terre
comme si tu les enchères et puis les
tirs autant de temps que tu veux c'est
la rythmique jeu les accords ouais je
regarde pas ta main j'ai dit ok ok
là en fait c'est facile je pensais pas
que ce serait aussi facile mais même
alors sensations j'ai trouvé ça sympa tu
as commencé par un phare exactement
après d'enchaîner avec un manager willi
indo exact où tu ne la fais une petite
fac avec un frein majeur à la haine ou à
venir bon écoute à ressentir c'était
encore plus simple que ce que je pensais
d'ailleurs je pense à leurs gardes
civils ont pourtant quand ce fait vous
d'accord tu ne dis pas ouais ouais ouais
je vais te faire un fait faire je suis
super dur je veux pas qu'on me dit voilà
c'est ça alors c'est difficile a
franchement non je suis tout ça pour le
deuxième coup on va faire plus compliqué
donc tu connais des chansons en quatre
ou trois accords oui tu peux en avoir
une en trois accords oui ok une chanson
en trois accords je vais essayer de la
retrouver mais c est plus difficile ce
coup ci tu as gardé les mains exactement
dans les positions comme ça alors là on
ne verrait pas alors peut-être justement
ça il faut que je fasse que deux mains
gauches
car voilà tu vas mettre la main gauche
comme ça et tu vas jouer rapidement les
trois accords c'est à dire moi je vais
faire un deux trois ans que c'est comme
si moi je faisais un accord deux accords
3 1 sur la corée est comme si tu les
placer sur le manche
ok voilà alors pour gagner ma passion
quand je dire top c'est parti
maintenant ok je pense l'avoir
je pense l'avoir est-ce que tu reconnais
bien les accords à l'oreille je suis pas
là rien de chaud mais je vais
reconnaître la rade ou pas non non
d'accord je dirais que le premier ça
fait ça alors non classés avec le
premier c'est ça
oui c'est un tour c'est comme ça que
j'aurais dit que le deuxième c'était ça
exact donc c'est un frère et le
troisième c'était ça exact
ses côtés une chanson ah bah c'est ça ça
a eu
faire danser écoute je sais pas ça tu a
bluffé c'est vraiment carrément clin
d'oeil daigle olivier il a vraiment une
chaîne où ils expliquent des fois des
chansons ou des trucs sur la guitare et
je le suis sur sa chaîne je vous
recommande de faire pareil je vais vous
mettre une petite fille juste ici pour
vous abonner à sa chaîne ayant et merci
à vous de nous avoir regardé dans cette
vidéo qui mélangent et guitare et
mentale et c'était une grande première
moi ça m'a plu en tout cas de me
stimuler à chercher des idées après avec
votre journée cool si la vidéo vous a
plu vous pouvez nous faire savoir en
laissant un petit comme on appelle ça
dans les accords on appelle ça le pouce
en l'air ou également vous abonner à la
chaîne et rendez vous demain à 17h pour
prochain mental là parce que c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
ciao